hey rich this is steven
jackson calling in from charleston south
carolina
just calling in with a question about uh
what to do when you feel like you've hit
a wall
um motivation wise
so i signed up for the 4x4 by 48
and just feeling pumped after doing a
couple of events before that
that my ultra running journey
was just on an upward momentum and
trained really well for the 4x4 and did
really well
but afterwards i feel like i have just
hit a wall with
motivation to keep going and keep
training for
the next thing so yeah in your
experience
and adam's experience what are some tips
to
overcome that little bit of plateau or
valley after a big event like that and
get back on the road feeling good and
not feeling motivated so
yeah man thanks so much for all you guys
do love the pod
the books i've been a follower now for
two years or so and hugely inspirational
thank you for impacting so many people
including myself so yeah man thanks
bye have you been to charleston i have
not
i've been to savannah which is like
charleston junior charleston
is such a cool place they should have a
swim run there it would be a great place
to i don't know
it's not that i'm aware of it they
should have one it's such a cool
city and there's so much water
surrounding it that you could like run
down these
historic streets and then jump in the
water and i don't know i think it would
be cool
it'd be amazing um stephen thank you for
your question listen
uh post-race blues is a normal response
any athlete who's been in the game for
any period of time
has peaks and valleys you hit plateaus
etc so i think you're
first of all like it's okay that you
feel that way
every athlete has gone through that it's
not abnormal
so i wouldn't beat yourself up for being
in that spot
and not only is it okay for you to take
a break i would advise taking a break
you can't just
power through race after race after race
after race and it's just this endless
upward trajectory it doesn't work that
way you have to
build in periods of rest
periods of recovery and that kind of
mentality should
apply to how you plan out
not just like your training blocks like
week by week
but also day by day and year by year
like these things
are seasonal right and you can't
if longevity is an aim or a goal
you can't just hammer incessantly you've
gotta you've gotta build this
into your program and now that you've
had a taste of this
hopefully you can understand why this is
so important
at the same time you don't wanna be that
guy who's rubber banding in and out of
shape gaining weight losing weight to
some extent
that's okay but you don't want to get
too far out of it
that when you get back into it you have
this you know
very long period of trying to get you
know lose a bunch of extra weight and
get into shape you want to stay in
contact with your fitness
so you never want to move too far away
from it
because it's so much easier to stay in
shape than it is to get totally out of
shape right and spend all your time
trying to get back
in shape and that way you never feel
like you're actually making progress
so a couple suggestions that maybe might
be helpful for you
first of all mix up your training and
you can do this
by cycling it seasonally like i
mentioned
try different things like if you're
running all the time get on a bike or
get in the water or go to a yoga class
or hit the weight room do
something else that breaks up the
monotony of just running all the time
i think is important and you got to keep
it fun and
not so serious like if you're always in
this performance mindset of chasing
these races
and these goals um it's easy to kind of
lapse into this
um you know this state where you're
taking yourself too seriously and every
like every minute you're focused on your
training
and you're going to burn out so you've
got to find the joy in all of it
um and i think if you can connect with
that that will build some longevity
into this journey that you're on
so again mixing in some strengths some
cross training
other aerobic activities summer's coming
up in charleston i'm sure there's
you know things you can do on a boat i
don't know like what you got what goes
on there
steven there is a swim run challenge in
june there you go i don't know what his
deal is of swimming but maybe he can get
into that i also think
and this is direct from the creator of
the 4x4 by 48 david goggins himself
it's important to stop over indexing on
motivation
because motivation is an unreliable
motivator yeah it really is we we tend
to think like
well i'm not motivated so i won't do it
it's very fickle it's very
temporal and it shouldn't provide the
foundation
of your why so instead i always tell
people
to think more about it in the context
of the values that you're trying to
prioritize so instead of saying
i don't feel motivated the idea would be
to say
i am an athlete or i am somebody who
does
hard things right to create identity
around it as opposed to
this fluctuating emotional state that
you can't really
create for yourself and i think if you
can contextualize what you're doing
in that manner you'll create a more
sustainable
fuel for yourself i also think that you
need to ask yourself
if you're training simply to get a
result
to say you did it or you crossed that
finish line or you hit that pr
or are you training because it does
bring you joy it's what
it's an expression of who you are
because if you think of yourself
as an athlete or somebody who does hard
things
then you understand that we don't train
when we're motivated to do so
we train because this is who we
are and what we do i like it that's all
really good i would just add
or just not even add but just like
emphasize what you said i think
david would tell you um if your brain is
saying i don't want to do it
then you flip that right away and say if
that's what he hears he's right out the
door
if he hears i don't want to that's the
[ __ ] you know he's like
just that means you have to go do it and
and you just force yourself to do it and
it does take time like you said it's the
same thing you're saying
telling yourself you're an athlete or
i'm someone who does hard things is the
same thing as saying well i don't want
to do it today
oh that means i have to do it today so
it's just
however you want to do it you're
training the brain to flip it
and i think he'd say that and the other
thing i would say is
i'm a big believer in cross-training
just like you said i think it really
does help it makes you it brings a fun
into it so whether it's swimming or
riding a bike or whatever it is um and
then
uh you know the
zone two training maybe he's running too
hard you know like
like zone two i've found like i enjoy
running
like in a way that i never enjoyed it
before it kind of takes the pressure off
like
you can feel tired and it's late in that
day or in your but you're like well it's
just a zone two run
right and you have to sweat it don't be
fixated on your garment and all the kind
of devices
and hold yourself to some standard that
every time you go out to train you've
got to be better and faster than you
were the day before
right if you just like decide i'm gonna
lay back and do you know
an hour of zone two you know then then
you still do get a sweat you still do
burn calories you still do get some
some positive energy when you're going
on heart rate too it's not you're not
measuring yourself
against a pace where then you either
feel bad or good about yourself dictated
by that you're just training where
you're at you're not training where you
think you should be or where you were
last year at this time
train where you're at love it
[Music]
you